hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're finally back on monster on a roll
that's been months since I've made a
video cuz it really hasn't been much but
I'm so pleased to announce that we have
lots of info coming for Monster Hunter
ice-born lots of new monsters coming
some that we know of something we've
never heard of before
which some of you monster honor veterans
might be pleased to hear that some
pretty nice monsters in the past series
are coming back as well some interesting
things that are coming new weapon
techniques new slinger ammo the whole
new Lou Cal and everything else like
that it was always like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the updates a Monster Hunter world as
well as the solo guides for every
monster Monster Hunter world and I
cannot wait to beat these monsters when
the game releases to have some guides
for all of you I'm gonna try to do just
about every monster because they seem
very difficult to fight and since this
is a type of master G rank which we'll
get into a little bit later might be
real interesting so as always like the V
if you do enjoy my Twitter and discord
to be in the description down below if
you guys want to check that out and join
those would be highly appreciated and
with that let's get started with the new
info for today so first up this is from
the spring update reveal on the Monster
Hunter twitch account which I was
watching well of course recording all of
this this is gonna the update is gonna
be coming out September 6th which is
actually very earlier than I thought it
was gonna be I thought it was gonna come
on November or December but for you PC
players they said they looked at a
possible winter release which could mean
anything from December or January so as
usual you guys are going to be getting
stuff a little bit later which sucks cuz
now you're finally caught up with
everybody but now you're gonna be behind
again I don't know why they do this
that's personally something I'm not a
big fan of but either way for most of
you which are console players you will
be getting it September 6 and to just
describe all of this this place looks
absolutely amazing it is a new locale
and it's all covered in snow and trees
and mountains and stuff and I will
explain what some of the monsters are in
the trailer but we have this Minotaur
looking monster this big fish with a
large spike and they look very exciting
to fight both of these monsters will
provide different styles of play and
will be very exciting what type of map
terrain and we can use that then like
boulders other walls or mountains that
can crumble or an avalanche stuff like
that since we are within a snow area
another one looks like a bat which I did
find out the name of it later in the
trailer but at this point I didn't
really know it but it is Narga Kouga for
anyone that actually knows who the
monster is but we'll be getting into a
little bit
and more later in the video but in this
trailer you can see his ass getting beat
by Rathalos or wrathy and I still mix
that up in my head so there is gonna be
of course a lot of turf wars and then
there's also going to be a new monster
which of course we'll get into later so
I'll just leave you with the name a new
monster called vel Cana
and just judging from the trailer looks
like it's going to be a new palico I
don't which can possibly revive you or
give you a great deal of your health
back if you've been falling over and
stuff like that so that's also good
stuff to see but yeah that was the
trailer but here are some more details
from the developers and what they've
stated so ice-born is obviously going to
be a big expansion for the main game the
stories this is that is basically going
to take after the events of Monster
Hunter world but on top of that there's
going to be a new rank called master and
currently a monster on our world we have
low ranked monsters high ranked monsters
and now the new one called master rank
and for any of you veterans it's
basically going to be the G rank of the
previous games according to the
developer so expect a very tough fight
there are all of this new destination
but speaking of the destination as
stated before it's a very huge snow map
and this is gonna be called hoarfrost to
reach there's there's also going to be
lots of snow effects added throughout
the area having trails of snow leave
behind you when you walk and maybe snow
falling from trees and stuff like that
but if you're a monster hunter veteran
you understand that snow areas will
decrease your stamina quicker because of
the snow and the cold but you can
collect a few plants to make hot drinks
and reduce those effects it has a
similar creature called the Popo which
are gonna be the endemic of life there
they look like mini mammoths stone bills
and Rhine beetles are also going to be
here as part of the map to add more like
leanness and stone bills and Rhine
beetles are also going to be part of the
map to make it more feel more alive
which is awesome and you can use these
snowballs that the Rhine beetles make
and make crystal burst which is nice
which because of course we always want
those and the new wing tricks of the
mapper and be called crow toes with the
of this new locale you can also use
these crow toes to get to a few areas in
the map one of them being a natural hot
spring this is going to work like your
hot drink so you can use this instead of
the hot drinks and you can show what the
local wildlife was gonna be sitting in
the hot spring with you and as well
you're gonna be unlocking a lot of areas
through in the map some of this will be
blocked off but the more story quests
that you do the more you unlock and the
developers have said that this is going
to be a lot larger than any region and
monster on a roll
so far but as for the juicy bits we have
to talk about the new monsters which is
of course gonna be my favorite part
since I've made a lot of guides on these
monsters in the past with Monster Hunter
world so of course I'm gonna continue it
with ice-born and the first one we have
a brand new monster called bond borrow
bond borrows the Minotaur monster we
talked about before he's gonna be the
brute wyvern type he's gonna be a very
early monster in the game who loves to
starve turf wars with other people as
we've seen on-screen before and he likes
to charge at you with this horn
so most of his attacks are gonna be in a
straight line that might seem very easy
but you also have to remember with these
horns in the snow and the horns being so
big he's going to be picking up a lot of
objects throughout the area so it's just
in this clip he was hurtling snow
carrying big large trees or trunks and
throwing them at you so you will have to
be aware of that because that can
actually extend the range of his attacks
and how long he can reach so definitely
be aware of the terrain that you're
gonna be fighting in or you might be in
for a very bad deal as for other bits of
lore he likes to eat a lot of plants and
drink from the hot springs and he also
likes sunbathing so you can show with
him in the hot springs he most likely
won't be attacking you even though he
loves to start fights so we can just
have a cool drink with him and the hot
springs chill out and have some good
times with him another monster is bee
Otis who's gonna be the fish from
earlier he's a very larger monster he
loves to hide and go underground from
the snow and then emerge from underneath
he can't attack you from inside the snow
I believe you can still do damage
because you can see part of his body but
to be the most out of your damage you
want to get him out of the snow they did
not state how to get him out of this
though this could be one of the screw
the screamer pods like Diablos that you
can use on Diablos so that might be your
a thing that you might need I'm not
actually sure that devs like I said are
gonna keep a little harsh hush because
they want us to be surprised and figure
it out for ourselves and as well for
some more lore by Otis as a carnivore so
he's going to be eating the poor Popo
throughout the world so rip those mini
mammoths they're really cute next is a
very popular monster within this series
of Monster Hunter and it is narco Kouga
who we saw in the trailer and he appears
halfway through the expansion is going
to be very challenging with Swift and
fast attacks with even more attacks that
haven't even been shown in the past
games so for newer players like myself
we're just going to experience all of
this at once and for the veteran players
you can actually get a little bit of a
twist because they got to give that
monster hunter feel and so there's gonna
be a bit new attacks and since the
terrain is different maybe we can you
a lot more abilities and boulders and
mountains to maybe bring him down
so either way it's gonna be a new
experience for all players playing the
ice borne DLC next up is the final
monster they showed and the name of this
monster is gonna be called Val kana he's
gonna be the flagship monster like Raffy
and a rathalos I keep forgetting who is
who he's an elder dragon with loads of
ice attacks Val kana is extremely tough
seeing as he's going to be an elder
dragon but they did not stay anything
from that they're not even gonna show
anything within the trailer they want to
keep it hush-hush like I stated to make
it a little bit more interesting I think
that's totally fine by me this guy is
definitely gonna be deadly so I cannot
wait to make a guide on him he's gonna
have a lot of ice attacks maybe fire
weapons are probably gonna be the thing
throughout this entire locale because
you're in a snowy area but that's just
assumptions from me
the next section was about the new
hunter actions with an ice born first is
a new improvement for the slinger you
can now use the slinger while wielding
any weapon in the game and it does not
have to be sword and shield which is
incredibly useful a couple new slinger
items one of them is called the clutch
claw this allows you to grapple on to
monsters and stop them in their tracks
once you cling on to a monster you can
do loads of different things one of them
being unloading all this sling or ammo
that is next in your little loadout it
right into its head which can either
knock it out slam into walls or traps
and then set it up a lot better with
that so that's always nice to see the
other is a power shot which can make
monsters to flinch easier and you can
actually use this during the great sword
combo so you can throw it on the sword
hit him with the new power shot charge
it up hit it again
throw the power shot and then for the
final hit the one that ever the one that
does the most amount of damage that
everyone always tries to amp up that
will be your full damage and you can do
even more than you possibly could before
with the dual blades for other dual
blade players like myself you can be
shooting these ball dodging with the
dual blades and you can even combo with
the clutch claw so that you can do a few
attacks go right up to them with the
clutch claw hit him a bit go back down
and it's just a bunch of combos to keep
the pressure on the monster and for you
bow gun range players there's also going
to be new mods one of them that they
teased is the ability to reload wall
abating which is super effective these
are only a tease of the options and I'm
assuming just about every weapon if not
all weapons within the game we're going
to be getting some type of new ability
or some type of new combo with these new
weapons so don't worry you're if you
didn't see your item being talked about
here there definitely will have to be
for each of the weapons in the game then
lastly for stuff before iceborn we do
have our contemporary Gurgaon tape which
is what everybody's been talking about
for a long time he will be coming into
the game Saturday May 11th I forget
forgiving worst time that might be
Saturday May 11th but depending on time
zones it might be the 10th for a little
bit earlier so you'll have to check
within the video which for me at least
is about two days of making this so it's
gonna be very nice he's gonna be a new
monster basically with new weapons and
tricks and movement abilities he's going
to be very challenging the main reason
they wanted to do this is because a lot
of players had the enjoyment of when
they played the beta on PlayStation 4
Monster Hunter they were all all excited
fighting their ghonte for the first time
completely new monster having no idea
what to do it was just a really fun
experience having this new challenging
monster right away so that's what they
wanted to do with the ark tempered
Mercadante having her ghonte be
president we've already faced him
multiple times people have probably
farmed him forever but now give him a
little bit of a spin and of course he
will come with the new gamma armor set
once you defeat him and according to the
developers it's going to be very
powerful but we already knew that it's a
gamma set and it's already it's Naga
ghonte set of all things and I see a lot
of players when I play multiplayer and
co-op experience stuff that a lot of
them have never ghonte stuff so he's
going to be farmed a lot as much as
possible to get the gamma gear and for
you PlayStation players in specific you
can actually get a movable background
for him on PlayStation and all the icons
are changed for it and you can actually
purchase that right now which is really
cool so shout it to you guys and then
the last bit of information is all you
have to do for this is just buy the
digital edition of the ice-born DLC if
you have the base game or you can buy
them both together
monster hunter world and monster hunter
world ice-born you could buy them
together if you do want for a bundle
pack there is no purchase there is no
pricing on what it is I'm assuming it's
gonna be $30 because that's usually what
expansions and DLC are but it could be
$50 I have no idea they haven't stated
that yet so that's just me giving out my
opinion on that and yeah that was all
the huge info that we got in about a 40
minute stream so yeah hopefully you guys
did enjoy that I am very excited for
ice-born I cannot wait to make all the
gods possible on all these monsters so
if we stay tuned to the channel I do
apologize for not posting a lot of
monster on her stuff there just really
isn't anything coming out new for the
game and I completely understand that so
you have to bear with me
but once Monster Hunter ice-born comes
out we got lots of new content to play
and of course
arched tempered no Gurgaon tea will be
coming in about a couple days so
hopefully I'll be making a guide on him
yeah I'd like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe for new like I stated I
covered the guides and the info on
Monster Hunter world so if you want to
be kept up to date with everything
happening within the game of Monster
Hunter world definitely stay subscribed
to channel and you're always having a
little bit of trouble with a monster you
can always check my channel for guides
I've made on the Elder Dragons of the
current game and then a few other
monsters before that like Diablos and I
of course will be covering all the
monsters for ice-born as well anyone
that seems very challenging although I
assume since this is master rank all the
Manzo's should be challenging so yeah
definitely subscribe to the channel my
two most recent videos are gonna be
popping up on screen you guys want to
check that out and I guys have a
greatest today peace out and enjoy
[Music]